voilà donc pour ce récit auto sylvain
lequel gauthier rybinski est avec nous
vengerons gothique on vient de vous
faire un point sur la situation à kiev a
soumis à à kharkiv notamment 13e jour de
guerre des victimes qui se comptent par
centaines désormais ce que la diplomatie
représente encore un espoir dans cet
enfer qui est en train de s'installer en
ukraine
c'est difficile à dire parce que si on
dit non c'est désespérant si on dit oui
on est naïfs pour vladimir poutine il ya
une chose très claire et ça les
américains joe baydan l'on dit dès le
début ils n'interviendront pas et l'otan
n'ont plus probablement qu là il y avait
quelque chose à jouer d'une manière plus
fine c'est à dire de laisser l'ambiguïté
sur le fait que l'otan n'intervienne
devrait pas vous le voyez bien
l'histoire de la sphère des corridors
est symptomatique de cela vadimir
poutine dans le même temps fait
bombarder les villes alors qu'il a
promis les corridors à leurs premiers
points ces corridors sur quatre les
trois premiers men en russie ou en
biélorussie
que voulez vous qu'ils arrivent eux à
des ukrainiens qui se réfugient réfugie
ray en russie ou en biélorussie c'est
absurde
heureusement il y a le corridor de
marioupol il y en a deux un qui va vers
l'est et qui serait qui mène en russie
et l'autre qui va l'intérieur de
l'ukraine donc là il a une valeur mais à
partir du moment où vladimir poutine dit
que il obtiendra ce qu'il veut soit par
la négociation soit par la force il est
très difficile de répondre à votre à
votre question alors ce qui peut se
passer c'est qu'effectivement alors soit
on est dans un cas comme la crise de
cuba en 1962
c'est à dire que on assiste à un accord
secret qui permettrait aux deux parties
de s'en sortir c'est à dire qu'à
condition que le secret soit maintenue
bien les deux pourraient avoir la phase
haute mais pour l'instant on ne voit pas
sur quoi
l'autre négociation possible et alors là
ça renvoie à la géopolitique du monde
c'est la chine c'est mettre la chine
dans le cou qui est s'est proposé comme
médiateur comme médiatrice
qui pour autant
du moins dans ses discours officiels
n'entend pas trahir la russie est-ce que
c'est étonnant d'ailleurs qu'elle se
propose comme médiateur dans cette
guerre oui parce que si vous voulez à la
fois elle est anti occidentale mais le
commerce avec l'occident est capitale
pour la chine et d'un autre côté on ne
peut pas exclure le fait que la
direction chinoise qui voit d'un bon
oeil les revendications de poutine par
ailleurs soit troublé par le fait que
cette russie qui est d'habitude un
vassal près vassal de la chine prendrait
la un peu son autonomie donc c'est là
qu'il ya un qui a un souci
si vous voulez les négociations
d'aujourd'hui il faut pas non plus être
trop
il faut pas dire on dit on va parler à
dire qu'il faut bouder son plaisir c'est
pas ça mais il faut être il faut
accorder une chance à ce que peuvent
être les négociations donc elles ont
lieu mais on voit bien qu'à chaque fois
comme cette affaire des corridors c'est
une chose dont le pouvoir russe se sert
par exemple ces corridors ils ont déjà
été utilisés en tchétchénie par exemple
évidemment à l'époque cette guerre on
s'en fiche et ici en occident mais aussi
la syrie c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
on donne de l'espoir aux civils et
finalement on bat en brèche cet espoir
ça a un effet démoralisant et c'est ça
aussi la guerre de poutine je veux aussi
sur le psychologique et des civils
gauthier l'allemagne à a lancé une
enquête a ouvert une enquête sur de
possibles crimes de guerre commis par
les soldats russes de quoi est ce qu'on
parle alors d'abord c'est une c'est une
un procédé ou un ou une façon de
procéder que l'allemagne s'est donné à
elle même c'est à dire qu'elle s'est
donnée une compétence universelle comme
la belgique j'avais déjà fait c'est à
dire qu'elle peut juger de n'importe
quel fai qui se passe dans le monde etc
est potentiellement un fait de crimes de
guerre ça veut dire que et pour
l'instant on n'a pas cette précision ça
veut dire qu'au fond il faudrait un jour
que cette cour où que le parquet
allemand remettent à la cour pénale
internationale
la volonté de
deux traduits en quelque sorte devant
cette cour devant ce tribunal vladimir
poutine lui même
là on risque effectivement d'avoir des
choses très intéressantes sur 20
intéressante pardon pardon de se taire
mis des choses probante sur des crimes
de guerre notamment ce qui concerne
cette ce bataillon de tchétchènes qui
appartiennent qui sont des vassaux de la
russie avec un un chef de guerre qui est
entraîneur de sabre rendre à kadirov eh
bien oui là il peut y avoir des crimes
de guerre d'autres crimes de guerre
parce que les bombardements convoqué les
russes procède par les intermédiaires de
chars de tanks sont effectivement
aveugle mais qui est l'homme qui décide
de tout ça au final est plus que jamais
c'est lui tout seul cela dit mercredi
merci beaucoup à thiais merci pour ces
éléments de compréhension